hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play when life
no longer exists it lingers and stuff
okay we just got out of an out-of-body
boobie experience and we need to find a
way out of here I'm guessing a crowbar
this it doesn't work like that well why
not what else am I supposed to do
there's not exactly a whole lot here
that you're giving me oh I see Oh duh
where did that come from
what does that come Bastion through the
Oh anti thief system haha
yeah no joke alright then dark in here
another anti thief system Kerch unk
anything something interesting happened
to the monster up here
v Luther can I talk really not no it's
your house man you own this place oh you
tell me huh oh I'm so sorry what did I
do wrong
what have I done stop stop stop oh I did
some horribly wrong there and oh maybe
that's how it's supposed to be oh yeah
yeah so smart and handsome and
everything - I found a curative liquid
that's the first time I got that I guess
they're aiming to hurt me now I'm too
much of a challenge for the Oh Oh be
distracted by that giant spinning wheel
evil monster from Hades
Hey look over there what was that what
the hell hey I think I can actually get
up here ha ha oh he'll never find me up
here I am too professional and easy
player hello oh hi nobody's home oh look
at that you busted the door good job you
dish you douche you there he'll never
see me he does he's so stupid look it up
a stupid hit and walk around naked Oh
stupid can you be
oh he's so dumb he doesn't even know he
doesn't even know he's so stupid
all right let's go didn't hear a thing
didn't hear a thing - oh whoops didn't
hear a thing okay
good moving forward cuz I'm awesome -
the sewer oh yeah when the lamb opened
the second seal I heard the second
living creature say come for then
another horse came out a fiery red one
it's rider was given power to take peace
from the earth and to make people kill
each other Tim was given a large sward
okay alright whatever whatever a large
sward can I have a large sward I had one
before it kind of went away see perfect
place for a water monster considering
there's water everywhere
oh hello is this something I need to
know about I need to I could break those
bars if I found his saw somewhere well
why specifically a saw I don't think I
could get through those bars with a saw
Oh
Oh I thought that cloud of smoke was an
evil demon okay so I just need to find
these recipes uh thingamabob errs and
then get out of here right maybe over
there hello hey what the hell did you
come from yeah the way I did it what the
hell was that you douche what am I doing
here
oh there's another one of these things
okay okay that's all I needed right
just the two already hop skip and a jump
running away SuperSpeed need to [ __ ]
galloway clothes damn it I think I
missed that what did I get it did I get
it I think I got it good Kent this is
why they were planted they're planning
on hurting me
come at me bro come at me bro
come at me bro are you that he's the
curative liquid get full health there we
go go go go go go go in yeah yeah close
how's it well done water monster part
made me going to situation where I had
that that's we got the signal yeah yeah
yeah all that stuff special prophecies
of end times and whatnot okay not going
back down there that's for damn sure
oh no oh this looks good hmm I've got a
good feeling about this
oh yeah 666 death awaits upside down
cross haha good thing that arrow is
pointing that way whoo I'm going towards
a safe zone
haha all right tariffs oh wait a minute
wait
ah hi how's it going good spent a while
fat you're doing okay see you been doing
those trunk rotations looking good you
looking buff man you're I don't want
look at ya cuz you're too intimidating I
just didn't want see your giant muscles
did he just poof he pouf didn't he you
know this guy makes a good custom story
but I gotta say his art skills are
lacking just sayin you know that rug
back there and the textures on those
swords and born and mad just look at
this thing man that's at something else
anyway enough criticizing other than
that is a really good custom story I am
quite enjoying myself hello
[Music]
okay Wow die here but Howard you come
from
would you come from that's not fair
uh-uh turn onto music it's not fair
what the hell you think you're doing
hello roaches are you hiding something I
know nothing glows in here so I gotta go
on my merry way
okay found that what do with that dough
nothing has a glow on it sorry I know
you guys can't see but I can't see
either
nothing is occluded I can't see anything
you still there go away go away go
[Music]
yeah so I don't know what that was I'm
making the monster sound like Santa
Claus apparently do I know I don't know
what that would do no I'm gonna find you
my home or rip it out okay here we go
it's last one yes oh hi hey guys oh you
don't good
yeah and you've been you've been not
skipping leg day I can tell you got it
get a good frame on your body there if I
was yeah yeah well if I was going for
that sort of thing I'd be all over you
you know box defense come here bro
yeah sup buddy Wow let me where I don't
know what huh
missed me oh you were a boo for anyway
kill me
why are you that kill me that shouldn't
that killed me
I was so close I was full health bull
bull that's what that was bull
pile of bull oh I'm all the way back
here but this was forever ago well not
forever ago it was like two minutes ago
but oh man I was so oh how about all the
monsters de-spawn - that's one of the
things that thankfully was gonna change
in the sequel and anime amnesia oh
machine for pigs they're gonna have
hello when the monsters show up they're
gonna show up randomly or you know
sometimes scripted I guess but they're
gonna show up randomly and when you die
they're gonna show up in a different
place or whatnot
either way it's gonna be much more
terrifying yeah sanctuary Oh No Tex all
right
oh hello hi are you that guy that I saw
before is that oh it is I remember you
nice Dingle bear no thank you
hello there is some time there's
something in the darkness the crucifix
protects you from it whatever happens do
not drop it or the darkness killed you
it's your only chance to get over the
darkness okay then don't touch that root
crucifix when you can do the double
finger defense got it
I busted dropped it to pick it back up
and it did not like that can I also yes
I can the power of the NFL compels you
the power of Kali mercury compels you
okay I can't drop it to pick up anything
right right that's the deal here right
right I can't drop it
I know drop e you know making me drop
you know make me drop well how'd it
hi-oh
oh the power of CNBC compels you the
power of Mortimer goth compels you ah
the power of silence compels you can't
see me can you ah yeah I didn't stop
banging your dammit stop banging around
Clank Clank Clank Clank Clank hi wow
you're really close ain't you you want a
hug
well that was stupid
oh it's stupid this is all stupid it's
just dumb why do I keep clankity clank
the thing on the thing and then it's
fair fine let's do this let's do this
scheisse come on you can't bring me down
I am amazing I'm a man hello hello hi
dear
well there's no barrel here now alright
nothing - nothing to block my way with
clankity clank therefore he'll never
find me right it's gonna bring this
closer I forgot that you could do that
no there's really cool but not I'm dumb
it's cool I'm dumb
I'm so scared ah
is he gone oh good Bo's I'll pee my
pants
whoo so scary I'll muster up the nerve
to move forward you guys but only only
for my lovely audience
oh hello look a bit of unending
blackness I like it ah there we go
do I place it on here ha ha ha ha ha
totally a guess but I got it
well considering it was the only thing
to do I guess I'm i can't pat myself on
the back too much or can i oh ok so now
I got the all right let's go pick up the
anti crucifix a little well then never
mind
go through this water part Oh lovely
well this looks familiar don't it huh ok
the water is lava ah I burned in the
lava yeah
mr. a I meant to do that yeah totally
totally man all right what do we got
here a choice huh
how about this one
was that my prize was that the right
choice or the wrong choice hang on these
upside-down ones are regular no they're
upside down
how about that but what what what what
happened oh there we go ha ha I got it I
feel smart even though I know I didn't
really do anything all right
ok it looks like you're getting that
place to end it so yeah thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]
I'm super they're dead oh well
let's get